[Music]
who likes to call 9-1-1 i did i have you
like it won't do it what do you like
about it i like it can we use them as a
delivery service
for pizza 9-1-1 i'd be like hello 9-1-1
there's an emergency what i'm hungry
if you're eight years old they'll do
everything and then you call them back
and say and breadsticks
july 16 is the official launch date for
the new 9-1-1 oh i can't wait rebrand no
way why why there a new one is it a tv
show no it's not a it's it's not even
number one it is a new three-digit
number you call
when you're specifically experiencing a
mental health crisis oh
so so kind of like how they had 4-1-1
before they had the phones yeah this is
the i mean the the smartphones 988 is
the new code
so if it's not something you want the
cops to come and ruin and it's like more
of just like a mental thing you don't
want to get you know killed 980. so
who's on the other end therapists like
professionally trained people who are
well equipped to handle that
yeah that's the current problem we're in
because uh
while the date is set for like when this
is all going to go into effect out of
all of the 50 states in u.s only four of
them actually completed the
comprehensive funding plans for these
things right everybody else is kind of
still figuring it out so
that's an up in the air answer so
they're hiring you calling you're on
hold the entire time dude who they're
gonna hire though a bunch of crypto bros
that would be bad news probably well how
would a crypto guy respond to that if
you guys would be like hi i want to kill
myself already oh you want to kill
yourself well let's talk
do you know how much i lost dude
the market is terrible right now it
could be an effective treatment though
like if someone dwarfs your problem i go
and listen to what i'm going yeah you
wonder what i did oh [ __ ] that's
actually a good idea we should try that
we should workshop it let's play the
fire so 988 that's what you call but
only colorado washington nevada lucky
for you guys and uh virginia are the
only it should be nevada out of all the
states nevada and jersey wherever
there's casinos true yeah because some
people like yeah they get into that uh
situation yeah but how many people are
gonna abuse this system
and prank call it
yeah
what would you say oh i'll just be on
there for an hour just trying monologues
coming in glenn gary glenn ross seeing
if i'm good if i'm any good because like
if you're convincing or not convincing
in your own mental health issues yeah
that was really believable you should
you should audition tomorrow well yeah
you should call 911
that's kind of interesting because uh
you know when you call 9-1-1 it's very
clear that they don't really want to
[ __ ] with you that long like they're
they're not they're kind of talking a
little shitty sometimes even they're
trying to like all right what's that 988
yeah personally for sure 988 they really
have to be sensitive so i don't think
they would be very quick to call you a
[ __ ] because what if all the states
that don't have the funding they just
send it to 9-1-1 dispatcher and then
they're picking up both calls and they
get all mixed up you know they're like
9-1-1 i mean 988 uh yeah what's your
problem i just think the lines are just
gonna be so congested super congested
yeah isn't there like a helpline where
it's like motivational or some [ __ ] like
that in one of those states i need a
motivational helpline like for public
motivation yeah where it's like there's
like oh [ __ ] you should do it man you
can [ __ ] do it dude don't be sick
what if we call that before we come into
uh work
today it's a robot dude
and it's like the worst sounding robot
yeah it's a robot the entire time press
one if you feel you can do the thing
what if the mental health people called
that number on accident and then it's
like hey man i'm not doing something you
can do it dude you can [ __ ] do it and
like yeah i'm gonna kill myself you can
[ __ ] do it bro
called the wrong one
oops
that's the oofy dude
you're too inspired to die oh damn well
so what do you think the reason is that
only four freaking states have their
[ __ ] together because people suck at
dealing with mental health like dude
you'll barely think it's real it's a
stigma for sure still yeah
dude because if there was a thing if you
go to therapy and you're a dude you're
gay yeah
don't say that [ __ ] bro you've already
seen people
you're getting
diagnoses it's true though like like our
generation and above oh it'd be like
that's true the first thing they'll say
is what's wrong with you are you gay
yeah yeah yeah i got called gay for
wanting to be a therapist when i was in
filling out my fafsa yeah i got i got
caught up with the agent was like oh
this guy's gay right i got called i
gotta call gay for making a space mobile
i was like 17 years old
what were the things you were dangling
from what'd you put on there i put the
styrofoam and you know you color it
mercury
i think that that's what we need to do
is we need to have a whole episode where
we talk about all the things we were gay
shame for when we were in high school
junior elementary all that stuff because
i just think like we need to really like
like hit those points and tell the world
what it used to be like i gotta call
gate for being in a play
i mean that's kind of gay bro
cats
cats is good
when i was playing dorothy on wizard of
oz people were like so calling me gay
i don't know why which one was it into
the west oh man i can't even remember
honestly because it was it just [ __ ]
you up so much they were calling you
he's like god
oh it was grease
oh who are you i was kaniki
that's the straightest guy in the movie
he's the most pretty guy there
apparently not
he made it gay did you play it gabe yeah
you played yeah he's like he has a
personal account that's his revenge
his revenge like you can call me game
get a plate
his director's like what happened what
is this guy i lost control okay he's the
star of the showdown
he's the kicker everybody wanna see
people call me gay for uh playing water
polo
wearing speedos all the time oh oh the
speedos was gay that's kind of weird
because didn't in high school we didn't
have waterfall in high school but i
always imagined water polo guys were
like the guys that all the girls were
going goo goo gaga over not at my school
when i was a virgin until i was married
[Laughter]
till last year actually because
waterfall guys always had that much you
know that v yeah yeah i mean but we were
a bunch of losers
mostly basketball players in my high
school
and football players were you guys
winning much is that why we were like
mid
we were like they're just splashing each
other
they're not even like yeah
there's no balls
it was a splash
contest it was good but we were good
though we were good at that we were good
though
the best splashers
jeez
wait nick you're playing you're doing
water ballet dude like no one you kept
calling it water polo but everyone knew
synchronized swimming there was never a
ball yeah
but don't throw that at me would a
trained operator on 98 have to say to
you if you were like hey
everyone keeps calling me gay
i'm not good
well are you in a play or something
[Laughter]
so i obviously am out of the job
but you would uh
[Laughter]
but the next no but like okay all jokes
aside i don't happen to be cats yeah
you missed your stop police are you
monko jerry
but you would ask like why why are
people calling you gay okay and then
what would you say mr caller they're
calling me gay for no rational reason
yeah because i look gay and then i'll be
like i'll tell you here let's be my
actual self okay that hat like what
would happen
they say you look gay yeah all the time
dude
my dad's tyler gay my dad too define
what game looks like i don't know but in
the 90s it just looked like anything i
don't know like because i had gel in my
hair i was gay oh yeah okay be the
operator be the operator yeah they said
i was gay because i have yelled at my
hair and i plucked my eyebrows a little
well do you do
do you like do a lineup on your eyebrows
no i just i just
plucked the unibrow part and they called
me gay well just make sure you don't
line them up because then they might
have some ground for cause i frosted my
tips oh that's it i don't talk to gay
people
[Laughter]
this is 1999 by the way and i did when i
went to a catholic all boys school in
the summer to do math with the don bosco
oh [ __ ] yeah we used to make fun of
those kids the students
like thought it was cool the teachers
were calling me gay they're teachers
that's crazy where is this exactly
it's a catholics wouldn't it
tech is in like uh san gabriel or like
uh i forgot what city it's actually in
you know what the rumor was well i think
it's montebello or san gabriel that's
the city it's in the group so so all the
neighboring schools we knew that there
was all boys school right and then the
rumor was that um all the boys of that
school were gay
all of them all of them yeah that was
the joke everybody would say about all
boys yeah that's a fact because it's all
boys school like oh they're kissing each
other for sure
and then there will be like these rumors
like oh yeah you know like they they
practice on each other and stuff because
they don't even have a chance to like
meet girls so then they have to practice
kissing with each other well the thing
is when i went this summer or even start
though
dumb 14 year old right like in the
summer charlie from truth
girls are a lot of rumors
yeah girls are allowed to attend there
at the summer so when i went there was
it was co-ed in the summer yeah
but i just remember when i came in there
you're not allowed to have diet hair and
then i had frosted tips 19.99 i'm sorry
i go in uh the dean of discipline tells
me to go to the office we go to the
office we're standing in front of like
three other faculty people i just got
there i don't know anyone and the
they're all just laughing at me in a
room
and then the dean guy he just goes like
he's like doing this get a load of this
guy bit and he's just like
he goes
you think you think a kid like this
makes stellar grades
and they were all just like dying
laughing and then he was like yeah you
could have to dye that back and then
they let me go and i was like that was
the start of my day one i was like [ __ ]
this school
yeah like you think he gets good grades
like why is that a joke i think it's
just because they knew i was an outsider
and they probably thought i was gay so
okay
wow how old were you 16. but that's how
prevalent it was though like
that [ __ ] would happen all the time
no no but like that type of behavior
from like a teacher to a kid you know
absolutely well because that's the sign
of the times too it's like not only were
like people calling each other gay like
by the drop of a hat but adults were
also doing that yeah you watch certain
movies that are made like 10 years ago
and you see how they like stigmatize
like gay people don't hold up well
they definitely don't write
even in sitcoms and [ __ ] like that oh
yeah totally they're just like these
like flaming stereotypes yeah friends
friends does not hold up well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you